みなさん、こんにちは、こんにちは。明けましておめでとう
ございます。
今年
は、このビデオで昨年よりもずっと良い年になります。
日本の音声学の次のエピソードを公開します。
別の常連客から直接連絡が
あり、別のレッスンを一般に公開することで発生する可能性のある損失
を相殺するために一時金を支払う場合は
、一般にレッスンを公開して
いただけませんか。
約1
年前
と同じように、同じことをした別の状況があったので、
これは
日本語音声学の次のエピソードです。
エピソード5では、日本語でピッチアクセント
について話し合うときにさまざまな重要な用語について話します。
これはオリジナルのエピソード5です
が、私はこのエピソードを作成
しました。この時点で約4年3年4年前に言いたい
ので
、レッスンの情報はまだ
非常に貴重です。  eしかし
、レッスンのさまざまなセグメントにumを追加したい
ことがいくつかあるので
、このショットと同様に、ビデオが続く
ので、視聴しているすべての人にとってより役立つように、いくつかの追加情報を提供します。
これを可能にして
くれた常連客に改めて感謝します。
皆さん、こんにちは。皆さん、こんにちは。
このエピソードの
ドーゲンによる日本語音声学の第5話へようこそ。今日は、日本語の方言のアクセントの用語
について説明します。
次の用語に対処するピッチストレス
アクセントダウンステップモーライントネーション
日本語のピッチアクセント用語に関しては、
リソースによって定義
が異なるため
、ここ
に示されている情報と他のピッチ事故リソースに示されている情報との間にいくつ
かの矛盾があると予想されます。 やろうとしたのは、すべての
用語を
、関連するすべての用語を
わかりやすい言語
の高低アクセントで提示することです。
厳密に技術的な観点から見た単語やフレーズの
owトーンは、
低音と高音の2つの音しかありません。
日本語のすべての独立した単語を
含む、低音と高音の両方を含む
ピッチアクセントパターンがありますピッチミル菊のいくつかの例を見てみましょう
高ピッチ
は大音量と同じものではないことに注意することが重要
です 低音から
高音へ
と変化します。低音から高音へと変化するピアノを想像できますが、
各音をほぼ
同じ力で叩くの
は正しいので
、単語やフレーズの高低音をピッチすることはできません。
ボリュームに関係なく、ピッチ
は最初
にもう少し簡単に触れたいと思います。
これの主な理由は、低ピットと高
ピットの違いを示すときに、より良い例の単語を使用できた
からです。
chは、それがheibongの
単語であり、その家族に属するすべての単語
は、
少なくとも注意深い発音では低音から高音に変化するため、変化し
ます。
母音が
食べて
特定の音の間に入るとき、あなたは
本質的にそれらを言わ
ないので、あなたが
言うeアーティキュレートでキーを言わ
ないので、実際にはそれほど
目立たないこと
さえありません
の最初の
音は実際にはピッチを保持していないため、ピッチの可聴変化。
このuhの例を示すためのより良い単語
はおそらく
鼻であるため、鼻も
低から高の爆弾ペイジャクソンファミリーに属し
、日本語で知っています。
それから、
ハイナハナと私は
ここにネイティブレコーディングを入れて、これを注意深く聞くことができるようにします。
tピッチと
iiiは、セグメントの終わりに向かってこれに対処し
ました。低音から高音への
違いは、音量の変化とは異なるため、
そうでは
ないと言って、低音から高音へと進んで
も、わずかな音があれば問題ありません。
音量は変わり
ますが、英語で
は、umという単語のアクセント部分を強調している
わけではなく、hanはとにかくヘボン族に属しているため、実際にはアクセントがありませんが
、ピッチとピッチの違いについてです。 力の変化ではない
ので、前に言ったの
は正しいですが、力が大きすぎると
間違って
いますが、eが無声化されているため、違いを区別するのは難しいですが
、そのような単語を使用すると、それは大丈夫ですが、
力が大きすぎることはありません それ
はあまり良くない
ネイティブ英語話者は通常、
ハナのような2つの道徳的な言葉でそれを行うのにそれほど問題はありませんが、あなた
が
頻繁にネイティブ英語話者を食べるような別の言葉をとった場合、彼ら
はおそらく賭けを言うでしょう
w 英語
の特徴の1つは
、特定の音節を強調しているとき
に力と長さを追加し、力を追加し
た結果、通常は
ピッチが上がることです。 同様
に重要なことは
、単語にアクセントがある
場合、または単語が低音から
高音に
変化する場合は
、単語の音量ではなく、ピッチだけを
増やすことです。これが最初に行うことです。
その最初の最初の小さな
セクション2のストレスに追加したい
音節の
単語またはフレーズに適用される力の量英語はストレス
アクセント言語であり、特定の
音節が他の音節よりも強い力を受けることを意味します。
周囲の部分の大学の大学よりも強い力を受ける
ので、いわばメンタルキーボードで
verを叩くと、他の音よりも強い力でverを叩く
結果、
ver
の音量が大きくなります。
厳密に技術的な観点からもう一度話すシティ大学は
、日本語の高低アクセントシステムの公式要素ではありません。
これが、
前述の
菊が正しく
間違っている理由です。この現象を非常に簡単に説明している日本の音声出版物をいくつか読んだことがあります。
英語とドイツ語の強勢と
弱点の違いを理解するために、
日本語の単語には高低のビットがあり
ますこれは、イントネーションが日本語の強勢に影響を与えると言われている強勢アクセントと高低アクセント言語の違いを説明する非常に簡単な方法
だと思います
そして、ビデオ
の最後でこれに触れます。
この用語は、
社会言語的意味での社会言語的定義と音声的
定義の両方を持っている、音節の単語またはフレーズ番号3のアクセントに適用される力の量を強調
します。 言語の一般的な話し言葉の特徴
であり、次のように使用されます。
ジョンのロシア語のアクセントは
、音声学ではほとんどネイティブです。  ics
アクセントとは
、話し言葉の単語の一部に明確
な強調を加える
ことを指します。これは、前に説明したように、この強調は強勢または高低アクセントのいずれかの形で発生する可能性があるためです。
英語
とドイツ語の話者は、強
勢を使用してアクセントを示します。
日本人の話者
はアクセントまたはその欠如を示すためにピッチを使用する
ので、ストレスとピッチ
はアクセントまたはアクセントの欠如を伝えるためのツールです
これは
、日本人の
話者のストレスアクセントとピッチアクセントという用語がピッチの違いを使用し
て明確なアクセントを明確にする場所です 単語
やフレーズ
したがって、日本語は高低アクセント言語の
4番目のダウンステップです。非常に
一般的に言えば、日本語
の高低アクセントパターンには、高低アクセントのパターンが3種類
あります。 低高低単語
は
ダウンステップを示します。これは、単語のどこかに、ミロ
で高から低へと変化するピッチの変化があることを意味し
ます。  r
これは私
とインハシルの間で発生しますこれは彼女とグの間で発生しますコクゴではこれ
はgとtの間で発生します
このダウンステップまたはピッチの高から低への変化
は日本語のアクセントまたはプロミネンスとして分類され
ます 高から低対
低から高
は通常大きいので、
すべてにアクセントがありますが、
この単語にはアクセントが
ありますが、ダウンステップ
がありますか？
アクセントを付ける
ここで重要なことは、
ダウンステップ
は日本語のアクセントまたは音声の卓越性で
あり
、すべてのスタンドアロンの単語は
ピッチに何らかの変化を示し
ますが、すべての単語にアクセントがあるわけではないため、
ここでも使用しまし
たが、そうではありません ヘボン語の最良の例は、その
単語
の発声のためにキートがピッチを保持しないためです
が
、この前のセグメントの最後のセクション
の
要点は、日本語に多くの単語があるということです
アクセントがない高低アクセントファミリーは
、ネイティブ
スピーカー
が最初に頭を包むのが
少し難しいものですが、日本の
研究ではすべての
単語が持っているわけではないことに注意してください アクセント
5モーラこの用語を完全に理解しても
、
通常、日本語の高低アクセントや発音は改善されないため、
非常に単純なものにしておきます。
アモーラは音節のようなものですが
、日本語では、すべてのフルサイズのひらがなまたは
カタカナの文字の
数が少し異なります。  1つのモーラまたは1つのビート
私のモニカには4つのひらがな
があるので、単語には4つのモーラがあります
が、音節を使用して数えると
、小さなひらがなまたはカタカナの
文字が
大きなものに結合する場合、2つのドーゲンしかないことがわかります。
単一のモーラとして数えられる
ので、kaishaのような単語がある場合、これ
は
3つのモーラとして
数えられ、小さなものは1つのモーラとして数えられます。したがって
、単語には
音節ではなく4つの使用モーラがあります。 日本語でビートを数える
ことができる6番目のイントネーションの単語の高低アクセントパターンを調べるときにこれを行う必要がありますこれ
まで私は
イントネーションと高低アクセントという単語をほとんど同じ
意味で使用
してき
ました。
高低アクセントという用語は、日本語に存在する標準的な高低アクセントの変化を表すためにイントネーションという用語を使用しますが
、高低アクセントパターン
は個々の単語の
教科書の高低アクセントの変化を参照するため、今後これらの用語を区別する必要があり
ます。
一方、フレーズイントネーションとは、このレッスンの開始に向けた話者の感情や動機に基づい
て、単語やフレーズの高低アクセントパターンがどのように変化するかを指します。
技術的な観点から、
日本人の高低アクセントは2つしかない
ということです。 ストレスは日本の高低アクセントシステムの公式要素ではありませんが、
これはイントネーションoの場合に当てはまります。
話者の感情や動機
を考慮
した日本語の言葉は
、ピッチの変化だけで
なくストレスも表すことができるので、
コンピューターが日本語を話すときは
低音と高音が2つしかありません
が、人間が日本語を話すとき
は広大な音色があります スペクトルこれは
日本の音声学ではかなり物議を醸すトピック
なので
、
午後のサスキーの出版物から少し読みたいと思い
ます。スピーチの重要な単語にストレスをかけること
はどの言語でも普遍的で
あり、日本語も例外ではありません。
ある人
が他の人よりも力強く音節を発音するとき、声のピッチは
わずかに上がります。これは自然な結果
です。発話により多くの力が使われると、
より多くの空気が発声コードから逃げる傾向が
あります。 その結果
、ピッチが上がり、
日本語のスピーチを参考にした日本語の音声学の力と声が大きくなります。  pt rootledge
library editions japan
suski pm suskiが言っていることは
、感情を考慮に入れる
と、日本語には強勢が存在し、高低アクセントと言葉
の高低アクセントがしばしば上がるが、
強勢が
日本語
に存在し、その強勢がピッチを変える可能性があるということです。
言葉の大きさと力は、日本語の高低アクセント
を勉強するのは無意味ではありません。
これは、
日本語の強勢が
高低アクセントの枠内で機能する
ためです。これが、高低アクセントを間違えたときに日本語の高低アクセントを勉強することが非常に重要である理由
です。
あまり
ストレスのない発話はそれほど大したことではありませ
んが、日本語に自信があれ
ばあるほど、ストレスのあることを言うときに単語やフレーズにストレスを加える可能性が高くなりますが
、高低アクセントパターンは間違っ
ています
高低アクセントを勉強しない人
が日本語に自信を持っている
ほど、実際に再び聞こえるのは悪い
ことです。
日本語のネイティブ教師が
生徒に
日本語はフラットな言語だと言う理由の1つは、
高低アクセントを勉強して
、ストレスをかけることができる場所とできない場所を正しく理解できるようにする必要があります。
これが、
私が本当に言いたかった最後のビットです。
私に関する追加情報日本語のストレスは
通常
、高低アクセントの枠組みの中で振る舞うと言い
ました。これが
、私が高低アクセントに留学していたときのこの高低アクセントの意味
です。
クラスええと、それまではかなり集中的に日本語の発音を
勉強していたので、日本語にはかなり自信
がありましたが、
高低アクセントではなかったので
、高低アクセントが
少し好きだとは知りませんでした。
それについて私はそれが存在することを知っていましたが、私はそれを勉強していなかった
ので、ええと、私は
私の友人の一人と会話をしていました
、そして私の友人は私に
何かを言ったと言いました eと
私が彼に答えて言ったことは、
私は学校を質問として質問として
言ったので、日本語で言うの
は基本的にほぼ
フラットなパターンで、最後に語尾変化が
あります
その単語自体
gokulは、私がgakkoと言ったのでは
なく、アクセントのないheibongファミリーの別の単語です。これは
、私のネイティブの英語
話者の
心が無意識に持っていた、または
正しい
発音
とその理由であると信じるようになったためです。 なぜなら
、日本語
には、構造に似ている
が、ええと、
ピッチのハックや家族が異なる単語がたくさんあるから
です。たとえば、
2つのカンジがある公式の単語なので
、その意味では学校に似ていますが、アクセントがあります。
最初の
モーラだから、私が挨拶
を質問として座ったと言ったら
、それは高くなり始め、低くなり
、最後に質問の変化がありますが、私は
imprの下にいました essionに存在する
アタモダカのパターンが聞こえたので
、無意識のうちに、
4つ以上の日本語の単語はすべてその家族に属し、
すべての単語にアクセントがあり
、正しい言い方
は高低または正しい言い方だと思いました。
学生は高低アクセント、
または銀行が高低アクセントであると言う適切な方法は
、ネイティブの英語
話者として
、多くの単語にアクセントがない場合、すべて
の単語にアクセントがあると想定する傾向があるため
です。 あなたは日本語ですが、
高低アクセントについて何も知ら
ない場合、アクセントでこれを言うと、言葉の中で再びそうすべきではない場所に自信を持ってストレスを加えるので、あなたの日本語は実際にはかなり悪く聞こえる傾向があります
その
最初のモーラで、または私が「がっこ」と言った場合
、その場合の会話は、私の日本語が本当にrのよう
だったという印象の下で本当にのようだったことを鮮明に思い出すことができます
私は日本の発音を勉強し
ていたので、クラスメートのほとんどがそうしていなかったので、とても
良いです。
配置やそのようなものii
は、私の発音が完璧であることを知っていて、
おそらく本当に
感銘を受けたと聞いたばかりの私の周りの誰もが大丈夫だと思いましたが、起こったこと
はその場で私の友人が言った
ので、一般的に言えば、私は学校と言うことができ
、追加することもできません 多くのストレスは
実際には試みず
、私が驚い
て
言っただけで大丈夫だという事実を本当に強調するか、私は本当に
ストレスを加え
て、私が驚いて言っ
て一般的に言っても
大丈夫だという事実を強調することができます
しかし、その
ピッチアクセントパターン
の範囲内で機能するその
から完全に異なるピッチアクセント
パターンに切り替えた瞬間、もう一度言います そのよう
なことは、
特に
ストレスを多く加えている場合に、ネイティブスピーカーに少し音が聞こえ始め、英語のネイティブスピーカーと同じ
ように
すべての単語が常に本で再生されるわけではない場合です。
彼らが文章で言うすべての単語のアクセントを注意深く強調
しないでください。それは実際には文章のレベルに依存し
ますが、明日言ったように1つの単語を単独で言っている
場合は、 明日は
、ほとんどのネイティブの英語話者にとってはかなり明らかな間違い
ですが、それ
は、
ネイティブの英語話者が
明日
、アクセントにまったく同じ量の力でそれを言っていると毎回言うという意味ではありません。 そして
それはいつも同じ
ですそれはあなたがそれらを知っていればあなたの話し言葉がもう少し自然に聞こえるようになるという一種の一般的なルールがあるということです
そして最後に私が話すこれを強調したいと思います
これについて
は、公開レッスンでもあるレッスン2または3だと思い
ますが、高低アクセントがオフになっていると世界が終わるわけではないので、大丈夫です。
多くの場合、人々
は
あなたが言おうとしていることを理解します。
とにかく、あなたが高低アクセントを持っていても、
あなたの日本語ではジャクソンの間違いを払っています
が
、日本の発音と高低アクセントを改善することに興味があり、
可能な限り
高低アクセントを勉強している人にとっては、高低アクセント
はおそらく 本当に良いアイデアであり、
それが私が可能な限りネイティブに聞こえたかった場所です。そのため、私は
ピッチアクセントを詳細に研究した
ので
、最後のビット
はセールスピッチになりましたが、
ここで反対の議論をしたいと思いました
高低アクセントがオフの場合でも、ほとんどの場合、日本語で非常にわかりやすく、ポイントを
伝える
ことができますが、ピッチを伝えることができるかどうかには違いがあります。
発音と話し言葉をできる限り改善しようとし
ているので、それはすべて
あなた自身の個人的な目標に依存します。
おそらく
このレッスンの追加情報としては十分だと思います。
ここで終了し、
残りの20秒程度を許可します。 レッスン
プレイアウト
じゃあまた
ね 日本語
の個々の高低アクセントパターンを分解します。
エピソード7では
、
次の研究を補足するために使用できるさまざまな無料のサードパーティツールを紹介します。ご不明な点が
ございましたら
、パトレオンにコメントを残して
ください。
ありがとうございます。
今後ともよろしくお願い申し上げます。また[音楽]お会いできることを楽しみにしており
ます。